we want to build a company off of praise
and not punishment and so what we
originally were saying when we started
acquisition.com is that the mission was
to make real business knowledge
accessible to everyone and that is still
very much the mission of Mosey media
what we realize is that holdcoast team
our heads of sales who build out sales
teams our heads of marketing who built
up marketing departments those people
didn't really resonate with making
business education accessible to
everyone like that wasn't actually like
what their mission was we got really
clear on what the mission of
acquisition.com is which is